it's a new week and a new chance for
your favorite games to get delayed today
we're talking about elden ring getting
pushed the gta trilogy achievements
leaking and giving an update on the ea
fifa negotiations as well as some marvel
movie delays my name is devonte chisholm
and you're watching gamespot news
so today's first story is a bit of a
roller coaster hold on tight first we're
going up let's start with the good news
elden ring is getting a closed network
test that begins on november 12th and
you can register now for a chance to get
in those who are chosen for the beta
test can take part in five different
sessions held november 12th through 15th
for three hours each time all right
we're going down here comes the bad news
elden ring has been delayed in a
statement from software said quote the
depth and strategic freedom of the game
exceeded initial expectations thank you
for your trust and patience going back
up the good news is that it's not a huge
delay the original date for the game was
in january but now it will be released
on february 25th 2022 going back down
the unfortunate news is that's the same
day as the saints row reboot and adding
to this february is completely stacked
with other major releases as well you
have horizon forbidden west dying light
to stay human the king of fighters 15
sifu and destiny 2's the witch queen all
i know is we're probably all skipping
valentine's day gifts so that we can
save our money for all of these games
switching gears now to the grand theft
auto trilogy the definitive edition as
the achievements have allegedly leaked
the list which was data mined from the
rockstar pc launcher contains the type
of achievements you would normally
expect like completing missions and
amassing a ton of money but a few
achievements seem to be references for
example the gta san andreas list
includes one titled here we go again
which is a reference to the meme of cj
saying the line in gta san andreas the
grand theft auto trilogy definitive
edition is set to release later this
year on ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series x
and s nintendo switch and on pc through
the rockstar game launcher with mobile
versions coming in 2022
and now let's move on to an ea fifa
update in a recent blog post fifa
announced that it conducted a quote
comprehensive and strategic assessment
of the gaming landscape and determined
that it will look to expand its business
dealings to other companies fifa even
appeared to take a dig at ea saying
quote the future of gaming and esports
for football stakeholders must involve
more than one party controlling and
exploiting all rights fifa went on to
say that gaming and esports are the
quote fastest growing media verticals
today so it is important for the group
to quote maximize all future
opportunities to leverage the growing
market the organization also said
multiple technology and mobile companies
are quote actively competing to work
with fifa but these comments might be a
part of an ongoing negotiation tactic
but now that we got all the gaming stuff
done with let's talk about some
entertainment news disney has delayed
several of its upcoming marvel movies as
well as non-mcu releases such as the
latest indiana jones film doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness was
previously scheduled to arrive in march
next year but will now hit theaters on
may 6th thor love and thunder will move
back to august 7th from a june date
while black panther wakanda forever
shifts from august to november 11th
inevitably the result of these delays
also has an effect on marvel movies that
were scheduled to arrive in late 2022
and 2023 in addition disney has also
pushed back the release of the fifth
indiana jones film an entire year and it
will now hit theaters on june 30th 2023
so we started the video with delays and
ended it with delays i'm so sorry to
start your week off this way but hit the
comment section and let me know which
game you plan on playing in february
because it seems like
they're just going to keep adding more
and more to that month and i just what
are we gonna do what are we gonna do we
can't play them all
or can we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you